[Music]
thank you very much for still being here
we've had quite a weekend and we've
heard a great deal about how the
election has been in a certain way
rigged if not without right fraud but
with the mail-in ballots and so many
other ways that can be manipulated to
achieve the desired result
now we've heard a great deal about that
I wanted to step back in light of all
that and look at some of the larger
trends like what is the end game where
does the Democrat Party want to be in
five years or ten years or 20 years
and I think that we saw that very
clearly on September 1st 2022
when Joe Biden made his Infamous speech
with the red and black background kind
of like this one all I need is a couple
of Marines and executive power and you'd
be in big trouble uh he gave his speech
that was really without parallel in
American history
there is no speech like that speech from
any president before Joe Biden it was an
extraordinary departure from 200 years
of American political tradition and it
was extraordinarily important
and I think it reveals
what the left is trying ultimately to do
the best analogy for that speech is not
in American history at all
it's actually in German history in a
speech that the chancellor of Germany
named Adolf Hitler gave on March 23 1933
in the reichstag
now you might say oh this is hyperbole
this is exaggeration this is crazy you
go to what is it called the Godwin
analogy or something Godwin's law if you
invoke Hitler then you lose well that's
all very well
unless you're talking about real
fascists
and Joe Biden is a real fascist
and the Democrat party is at this point
a fascist party now before you dismiss
this as hysteria or hyperbole let's
think for a minute about what exactly
fascism is people throw the word around
a whole lot Joe Biden has called
conservatives fascists and Trump
so nobody actually stops and says well
what exactly is a fascist what do you
mean by this
now
fascists
the word
means bundles
bundles
and it's like bundles of sticks if you
take out a dollar bill right now and
look on the back there's a fascist
symbol on the United States dollar bill
it is the American Eagle clutching a
couple of bundles of sticks
now why on Earth is the American Eagle
clutching bundles of sticks because a
single stick is weak and you can snap it
but if you hold 20 sticks together you
can't snap them
so the whole idea is out of unity is
come strength
and so the statement a Pluribus Unum
which is on the dollar and is one of the
mottos of the United States out of many
one that's a fascist statement
because it is saying that we are all
stronger together
than we are separately now I hasten to
assure you I am not saying I'm not some
craze leftist who snuck in I am not
saying that the founding fathers were
fascist or that America is fascist
actually it was not because fascism
actually the founding fathers were not I
mean fascism as an organized political
system an organized political ideology
arose in the beginning of the 20th
century in Italy and of course spread to
Germany and elsewhere
and was thought to be completely
discredited at the end of World War II
however the People's Republic of China
today is more fascist than communist
and Joe Biden's United States of America
now I'll explain this
when Adolf Hitler came to power there
were a lot of socialists in his
government
because after all his party was called
the National Socialist German Workers
Party and there was a lot of what we
would think of as leftist Marxist
rhetoric in the Nazi program
and there were people who wanted him to
nationalize all the industries
but he refused instead he called in the
captains of industry the big
industrialists in Germany and he made it
very clear to them that they would do
exactly what he said or they would be
killed
and they did but they maintained
ownership of their Industries
so in other words communism nationalizes
seizes control of the means of
production fascism does not fascism
allows for private ownership of the
means of production but coordinates them
all out of many one
bundle of sticks coordinates them all
together to work for the same goal
so they're both totalitarian systems
they're both very similar the idea that
fascism is Extreme right and communism
is Extreme left there's nothing to that
that's actually leftist propaganda the
reality is is that they are very closely
aligned they're very similar they're
both totalitarian systems that
extinguish individuality and coordinate
everything for the good of the state
and the only the primary difference
there are two primary differences
fascism tends to be nationalist
and fascism does not seize the means of
production but merely controls the means
of production now think about the United
States and of America today
what we have is
a president of the United States and his
party with one point of view
and as it happens that same point of
view is shared by all the major
corporations all the social media Giants
all of the media what do you call that
that's fascism out of many one bundles
they're all bundled together
and they're all working for the same
goal
now of course we know that very recently
there was this big fly in the ointment a
spanner in the works that Donald Trump
became president and so the whole
fascist Machinery was stopped in its
tracks because suddenly the executive
branch of the government was not on
board with the rest of the program and
so they had to get together and do
everything they could to remove and
destroy him and Joe Biden just repeated
that do you know that after after the
election right on Wednesday November 9th
Joe Biden was asked about Trump and he
was the questioner said his movement is
still very strong and Joe Biden laughed
derizzidly and said oh yeah
because he thought that it's broken and
he said I'm making sure he under
legitimate efforts of our constitution
does not become the next president again
that's what Joe Biden said now if you
think about that
what does that mean how can Joe Biden do
that I actually checked the Constitution
this morning just to make sure
and there is nothing in there
about eligibility for the presidency of
the United States except that you're a
natural-born citizen and you're 35 years
old
and you can be removed from office
impeached
and
convicted if convicted removed from
office if you are guilty of high crimes
and misdemeanors now that might be what
he's saying that they're going to indict
him for treason for something related to
these allegedly classified documents
that he allegedly had and so on and that
that will be considered high crime and
misdemeanor and bar him from the
presidency
but what he's really trying to do he
made clear on September 1st
and that was to criminalize opposition
to make only one political point of view
acceptable in the United States and you
can see that that is exactly where
everything is tending
in the fascist system in which we are
living today
the social media Giants have already
made it normalized that people who speak
things that are unacceptable get banned
and some people protest for a while and
everybody forgets about it and we go on
and there's this big debate because Elon
Musk bought Twitter over whether he
should allow the freedom of speech and
how much he should allow it and Joe
Biden actually says that we're going to
investigate him for daring to
try to reinstitute the freedom of speech
so how much does this Administration
value dissent this is an Administration
that put together the disinformation
governance board last year that was
going to work out of the Department of
Homeland Security quite ominously
in order to combat alleged
disinformation judged of course by the
board itself
and prosecuted presumably under the
auspices of being a national security
threat and so back to that red and black
speech on September 1st 2022
incidentally the 83rd anniversary of the
beginning of World War II
Joe Biden said that Trump and his
supporters represented a grave threat to
the Republic itself now that was what
was so unprecedented in American life
and that's why his speech was more like
Hitler's reichstag speech than any
speech of an American president
because Joe Biden was saying that
essentially half of the electorate and
everybody in this room
is somebody who is a threat to the
Republic
is somebody who is outside the bounds of
acceptable political discourse
so if you think that they are going to
peacefully allow everyone
who believes the way that we do
to re-capture the White House or the
house or the Senate and do nothing about
it then I'm afraid that you've been
naive
this is an effort to rule out Trump
supporters that is America First
Patriots
to rule them out of bounds to
criminalize that perspective
what Hitler did was in response to the
reichstag fire you've all heard of the
fire on the reichstag in the reichstag
February 27 1933 Hitler blamed the
Communists for the fire
and he banned the Communist Party
now as it happened the Communist Party
had enough deputies in the reichstag to
prevent him from being able to pass the
enabling act that gave him dictatorial
powers
and so lo and behold the Communists
aren't there
because he blamed them for the right
stag
he Outlaws the party then he has a
majority in the reichstag on March 23
1933 he said these people are a grave
threat to the Republic
and so we have removed them
the rest of the deputies vote in favor
of the enabling Act and the Nazi
dictatorship is established
now in the United States of America it's
happening more slowly we have a long
democratic tradition theirs was 14 years
old at the time that Hitler made his
speech that's not very long
but ours goes back to the 18th century
so it's going to take a while longer we
had the reichstag fire that was January
6th
the event that is
cast as high treason and the blamed on
the opposition group
and we had the speech that was
consciously I mean somebody made a
decision
to put the red and the black did you see
all the red and the black pictures
somebody decided hey let's get the Nazi
colors and put them behind Joe Biden who
who thought who decided that and why
it seems to me that it was very clear
that he was saying we have the military
behind us
and we are going to come after you we
are going to make what you were saying
and doing a criminal act
and we're going to rule you out of the
political life of the United States of
America
and so Joe Biden
in doing that
you see
is doing a quintessentially fascist Act
he's got all the corporations and all
the media all the industries behind him
they all work for the same point of view
and now he is moving to
eliminate the opposition so when we look
at the election of 2022
it's very clear what happened there was
a very
decisive majority for the Republicans in
the popular vote
and yet it didn't translate
to seats in the House of the Senate why
not because they've already rigged the
maps as we've discussed here several
times during this weekend the
gerrymandering has been quite successful
so that Republicans won big in their
Republican districts but it didn't
translate to Statewide victories
now that is the same effort you see that
is all one step toward
eliminating the Republicans altogether
or if not the Republicans eliminating
the Maga Republicans
Lisa murkowski Mitt Romney Liz Cheney
they'll be the acceptable opposition
but you see the acceptable opposition is
a controlled opposition is an opposition
that doesn't really oppose
that just goes along
and this morning I saw that at Arizona
State University which must be around
here somewhere
they voted 90 percent 90 percent for
Katie Hobbs
now
it reminded me what was really
disconcerting about it actually was that
this was on a on a Twitter post a tweet
and all the responses said hey Bravo gen
Z hey this is great
we love the young people they're saving
us
but what I thought was gee that reminds
me of the Soviet Union
and when they would have elections they
had free and fair elections and 99 of
the people voted for the Communist Party
and so the same thing has been set up
organically here those people are going
to grow up and they're going to be the
only ones voting and they're going to
vote 90 95 90 99 for the establishment
Democrats
so this is unfortunately
I understand a very Bleak picture and
I'm sorry to come to uh the morning
breakfast and give you a load of bleak
but
the fact is
that even amidst all this the light of
freedom is never extinguished
and they're making all these plans we
need to be aware of these plans one of
the most disconcerting and disappointing
things I think out of the 2022 election
was that I didn't see any Republicans
talking about any of this
I saw Republicans talking about
inflation which is important
and the border which is important not
taking away from any of that but where
were the Republicans talking about hey
you know this is a fascist
Administration that's against our
freedoms this is an Administration that
is trying to dis to to to to foreclose
on legitimate political discourse
this is an Administration that is
consciously aping the institution of
authoritarian totalitarian regimes in
recent historical memory
did you hear anybody say that I didn't
see anybody say that
but it's very clear you know you know
they sick to the FBI on parents
protesting at school board meetings
they keep saying white supremacists are
the biggest Terror threat that the
nation faces have you seen white
supremacists flying planes into
buildings
have you seen white supremacists blowing
stuff up I I don't I don't see it
but they keep saying it because of
course what they mean is the Maga
Republicans are white supremacists and
we're going to take away the franchise
from those white supremacists and
Destroy them utterly
anyway I'm saying it's not so bad so I
will end with that
remember that
one of the reasons why we have had Mass
migration into the United States was
because the Democrats assumed that
particularly the Hispanics would be
completely on board with them and would
give them a reliable voting majority for
the foreseeable future and that's all
Fallen apart
and the more yes and the more that it
goes on the more it will continue to
fall apart there are a lot of people in
the United States who believe that
there ought to be the freedom of speech
and so even though there's an alarming
number of people who are against it and
it is undergrave threat today at the
same time there are a great many people
who are not willing to see it go
and it will not go lightly
but it's going to be tough times ahead
and so Mike said you know he'll tell you
the title of his new book and I'm sorry
for the ad but the book will be out in
January it's called the Sumter Gambit
Gambit the Sumter Gambit referring to
Fort Sumter and the subtitle is how the
left is trying to foment a civil war
because you notice also how crazy
everything's gotten lately
that there's drag queens and primary
schools
and you see one story over here and you
think gee that's terrible and you see
another one over there and then you see
another one every day and it's happening
in schools all over the country suddenly
everybody's decided what we really need
to do is sexualize five-year-olds and
have pornographic displays in front of
them
well I don't know who's paying for that
somebody is
but
that is just one example of how the what
the what the immediate next step is and
that is to push us and goad us
until we strike back violently
and then if we strike back violently
then they can arrest us and put us in
prison
wholesale
and so the idea is with all this to
drive us crazy
and to say I can't believe this is
happening and we have no recourse at The
Ballot Box
what can we do we the only thing we can
do is go shoot up some government office
or something like that and that's just
exactly what they want to happen
and so a lot of this the reason why the
imagery of Joe's speech was so
flamboyant
and so in your face
was because they want us to notice it
and Strike Back
and then they can use the strike back to
justify further authoritarian measures
and so above all we have to not fall not
Take debate
and proceed peacefully but all the more
energetically to tap the sentiments of
those who did give us this big majority
and do everything that we can to restore
the Electoral viability of that majority
and to roll back in the with the heroic
efforts of people like J Christian Adams
and others to roll back the gains that
they have made to rig the system so that
even when we win we lose
so
I will close by noting that I am from
the great state of South Carolina
and I know you probably wouldn't believe
that but anyway uh
it's true
and uh the state motto was Doom Spiro
Sparrow while I breathe I hope
and so we must never ever give up above
all
and if we do not and insofar as we do
not we will prevail thank you
foreign
okay yes sir
yes
well that's another thing yes secession
the gentleman said secession comes to
mind and I didn't mention the night of
the Long Knives on June 30th 1934. in
the first place secession I think might
be a great idea if they would allow us
to go peacefully but probably they
wouldn't
but at this point the gap between the
two groups in the United States is so
large it's hard to see how it can be
bridged and so maybe it is true that it
would be good to go our own way
but I don't think that is a viable
option in terms of being possible in a
peaceful manner
we'll see maybe as things develop as far
as the night of the Long Knives goes
yeah I think that kind of thing is
coming it's just the next The Logical
Next Step once you say the Trump
supporter the night of the Long Knives
By the way was after Hitler became a
dictator then at one point at one night
he had thugs go around and kill all his
political opponents all his major
political opponents the former
chancellor of Germany and various others
and
that's coming because this is what
totalitarians do this is what fascists
do and these people are fascists
and oh you know I didn't I didn't
explain excuse me as an aside the
People's Republic of China is more
fascist than Communists today because
they have private ownership
they don't have nationalization of the
means of production they have
entrepreneurs but they all do what the
state wants them to do and so it's a
fascist State and that's what we're
working toward here
anyway the you rule out one group from
acceptable discourse you say they're a
threat to the Republic then killing them
all is
really a no-brainer it's the next step
hello
sometimes I feel that when I've been
listening to all these speeches that
we're giving Joe Biden too much credit
um I think that it this really started
with Obama and I think that Obama is
still behind a lot of what is going on
um and that Joe Biden Biden is just the
puppet oh you're quite right yeah I I
have to say I had limited time this
morning
and so I did not say that Joe Biden is
not really the president of the United
States but I think we all know that
uh Joe Biden is just a stand-in for
probably for Obama Susan Rice Valerie
Jarrett other people who were running
the show he's him he himself has made
that abundantly clear on numerous
occasions saying you know I'm going to
get in trouble if I depart from this
script and I'm told I have to call upon
at these ridiculous press conferences
he's he's it's very clear he he openly
because he's got dementia he just says
whatever's in his head and so he may he
said several times he's not the man in
charge he's just taking orders and this
did a lot of the Machinery of this did
begin with Obama uh the
totalitarian tendencies that we're
seeing come to fruition now he did plant
the seeds for them to a tremendous
degree
hi Steve hi
um to what extent was January 6. a
planned Democrat
um
plot oh I'd say about 100 and I mean we
know of course that they refused the
National Guard in advance
last night he mentioned the
huge bronze doors were already open yeah
yeah it's abundantly clear January 6 was
a setup the National Guard was refused
as Steve pointed out the doors were
opened by the police that's on video
and then of course there's the famous
Ray Epps you probably have all heard of
Ray Epps but just in case you can find
abundant videos of this fellow with a
Maga hat and he's saying we're going to
have to go into the capitol we're going
into the capitol
and he has not been arrested if anybody
was a ringleader of any kind of
insurrection it's Ray Epps and yet he's
one guy who's completely escaped
prosecution now that of course is
abundantly clear the guy was a plant he
was probably FBI he was trying to go to
people to go in so they could create
this incident that they could use the
whole thing maybe a few people went into
the capitol thinking they were going to
do some damage but mostly they opened
the doors people went in you know hey
I'm gonna take some pictures of the
Rotunda or whatever
they had no idea they were participating
in an Insurrection and what's being done
to them is Criminal but that's what
fascist regimes do they have to find a
scapegoat and a political enemy that
they direct hatred toward and use as a
springboard to criminalize and silence
all their opponents
you mention
um
hasn't been said out loud here is we are
living as you say in a new world
um
at this moment someone is surveilling us
that goes without saying
when the people on the diocese call you
Heroes you are
because at some point
you'll be challenged
um I worked in the surveillance industry
my entire career
someone here it doesn't belong here
they are working for someone else
and you're smiling you know no I think
you're absolutely right I just think
it's kind of amusing because maybe you
know I always wonder when they have
plants like that if they ever learn
anything yeah and whoever's got me under
surveillance I know you must be very
bored and I'm sorry and and you listen
to him as he makes the disclaimers I put
my cell phone
in it
in a wire mesh wallet
so they don't listen to my conversations
because if I'm put on a list
and I open my mouth
a machine somewhere in the bowels of the
government records what I say if the
words that I say trigger it there's no
doubt about it yes it's not a joke
they spent a trillion dollars plus on
setting this Machinery up China has
spilled spent three trillion dollars in
their money
on a machine that's even more Insidious
beware be ready speak softly
I want to assure you I was not making
light of your statements I I totally
agree this is uh just a fact of life
really I mean we all carry around these
surveillance devices with us all the
time
and you know I could tell you a lot of
stories about when I've been chatting
with people about a certain subject and
never looked it up online or anything
and then I go online and I see all this
information about it so some automated
thing probably was listening but this is
just a fact of life in America today
and we have to be we have to reckon with
the fact that they are looking for ways
to get at us
and to destroy any opposition that they
face and so we may come up against that
that's just the way it is and we need to
have the courage that the founding
fathers had
hmm mm-hmm
we have time for one last question if
anyone has a question
it's fellows nobody else has their hands
up
watched
I love it
um do you think that
um our military even though it's now
becoming
infiltrated as well that if there was a
order given to go after the citizenry
that the military would actually obey
that order yeah I think they would I I'm
sorry to say that but I've seen so much
of the police
you know I used to think well the police
you know if you're going to be a
policeman you're generally a good Law
and Order guy and so you're a patriot
and you love this country and you want
to see it be safe and free but then I
see police just doing the bidding of
these totalitarians
and they don't seem to bat an eye
and we have to reckon with the fact that
some people are just going to say I'm
just getting a paycheck and I'm going to
follow orders it's it's a unfortunately
a a
phenomenon that has abundant historical
precedent most notoriously of course
during World War II with the German army
thank you thank you
[Applause]